wow thank you thank you so much I wish  ways to never forget where I came from  and to always remember who gave me my  first opportunity I am so happy to see  Steven Spielberg here tonight Stephen  thank you  wow holy smoke when I started my career  as a child actor I felt so very lucky to  have been chosen As I Grew Older I  started to wonder if that was it if if I  was just luck for so many years I was  afraid I had nothing more to offer now  no matter what I did I would never  surpass what I achieved as a kid  thankfully more than 30 years later two  guys thought of me they remembered that  kid and they gave me an opportunity to  try again  foreign  [Applause]